hey everyone this is steve weintraub
with collider and i am absolutely
thrilled
to be with this gentleman i am a huge
fan of your work and my audience knows
please you need no introduction i'm um i
want to thank you so much for coming in
today uh and for all the years that
you've
been working in cinema and all the
documentaries and all the films i really
want to say thank you
um i know that you you are one of the
things that i'm fascinated by is you
have so many different interests and you
have pursued so many different aspects
of the film business and the different
projects that you've made what was it
about
this project that said i need to make
this i want to explore the brain
uh well there's a couple of things going
on at the same time
because this within a few weeks now i'm
releasing two new films and two new
books
so i'm i'm also writing and it
translates more and more that
probably my writing my poetry and my
prose
will live longer than my films i keep
saying that since decades but to this
one theater thought
about
what is going on in our brains
we know very little but now it's
expanding knowledge and science is
expanding rapidly and it's a
period that is
almost comparable to discovery of
the functioning of dna
which had massive massive changes
in the entire world for everyone what is
coming at us is
finds an audience finds a world
unprepared
so massive incredible advances
and of course it's a mystery and i've
always made films where
there's a sense of awe
curiosity and awe
and when you see
somebody reading
the beginning of my next film
without me even using a camera just with
a chip implanted you could
you could tell what what my next film
might be it's not that far but it's kept
getting close or
blind who are seeing again
rudimentary but it will be much much
better
people in wheelchairs walking again
because you can bridge
damage of the spinal cord
with fiber optics and implant chips in
the brain telepathy
and of course
we have to be aware that they are
dangerous
what if you can read my thoughts pretty
precisely
what happens uh if this ends up in
the hands of a rogue
secret service somewhere
but that's one of the things that i
found fascinating about your movie is
that you explore what people are working
on but you do come back to the fact that
technology 20 or 40 years from right now
will be so different and what we will
have learned about the brain the ethical
implications of this technology and
that's one of the things your film
touches on yeah but it's not only
negative definitions
thou must not thou shalt not read my
mind unless i consent yeah the privacy
aspect yes and the autonomy of our
thoughts you see we have gotten
accustomed to the idea that there is
freedom of speech a human right but now
there should be freedom of thought that
should be protected but at the same time
let's assume
uh
you had a massive stroke
you are paralyzed you cannot even answer
with blinking with your eyes
you have the right
even though you cannot tell about this
right that we implant you with a chip
which gives answers to questions are you
well are you thirsty are you in pain and
we could read and even language can be
read
very very fast and very well nowadays
with chip implants and some of the
implants
is tiny
tinier than dust mite tinier than
anything you can imagine
one of these little chips or 100 000
of these
dust particles would fit into one grain
of sugar
and you can put them in the bloodstream
and
and somehow direct them to your
cortex somewhere
so of course there are phenomenal
possibilities
glorious possibilities
but
of course i do not want to be implanted
against my
against my knowledge and against my will
one of the things that um you have an
advantage of because of who you are is
you were allowed to go into this ibm
quantum computer room you are able to
talk to these world-renowned
you know nobel prize-winning type people
um
who was someone that you were able to
talk to that you were really surprised
you got access to or at this point does
nothing surprise you no
it was basically not me but my
main scientific advisor world-class
scientist rafael usted
who
has done breakthrough discoveries and
he's studying um
tiny creatures hydras that have only
it's it's water creatures
uh that have tentacles and that little
stem there are few millimeters and you
find them in ponds outside of toronto
you might find them as a nuisance in
your own aquarium and they have
something 300 400 neurons and they can
do amazing things they can even
somersault
and move on because i have only one stem
as a foot
and and the scientist who has
80 billion neurons cannot some assault
so but through him i had access to the
creme de la creme of
of researchers
but sometimes i would for example a
nobel prize winner who has
worked or has gotten the nobel prize for
describing and discovering the
functioning of the sense of smell and
all these complicated structures memory
and smell and whatever and i talked with
him about talking parrots speaking
parrots and about what makes a what
makes a good marriage because he's with
his wife who is an equally wonderful and
outstanding scientist and we speak about
marriage and talking parrots
i'm so curious
how does it work with you and the
creation of one of your films like this
is it one of these things where you
decide one day i'm interested in this
i'm gonna go start filming or is it more
thinking about it six months in advance
no no it's
whatever i have done in my life feature
films included came with an incredible
vehemence at me
there was something dormant yes i was
always fascinated about the mysteries of
what is going on in our brain how do we
change our memories how they are
unreliable we we shape our own memories
much of what we are doing is
performative we live in
certain fictions
when you are a best man in a wedding
your behavior and your role in your
performance is different if then let's
say you are serving in the army or you
speak to your own children
you speak with a different voice you
speak as in the role of a father so
there's a lot of mysterious things that
are so evident in going on
and yet
they're crazy
other things where
we are talking ourselves into something
that never happened and we we maybe in
part of us lives in illusions
oh i was going to say that one of the
things that your film talks about or and
made me really think about and it's been
talked about in certain movies is the
fact that at some point in the not so
distant future
society will be able to implant thoughts
in your head or will maybe possibly have
access to this and then what makes you
you who you know what i mean yes sure
we know what's coming and we better look
out
and understand what is coming and that's
part of why i made this film you have
made so many
uh projects and you've done so much work
when when people meet you i'm so curious
is there one or two things that people
always want to talk to you about or is
it very so wide because of your diverse
resume no i think it's yes diverse yes
but
there's very very clear common
denominators
you can immediately tell this is a film
by me even if you haven't seen the
credits 60 seconds into it you would
know it must be from me
because i think there is a common world
there's a world view
there's a sense of awe there's a sense
of excitement there's a deeper vision in
it so many things that that all coalesce
and all come together and and all of a
sudden you
you have a film and they normally come
out of nowhere and in this film didn't
come out of nowhere because
in my
peripheral thinking so i i always kept
wondering what the hell is going on in
my own head and in your head and in the
head
of everyone else
and
i met
rafael yoste the scientist
and all of a sudden there was a movie
and and within
very short time i started shooting
no pre-production uh now looking out for
finances i i started financing it out of
my own pocket i wanted to go right into
it and it was right at the end of covitt
restrictions
and i wanted to start right away
because a lockdown next lockdown was
around the corner
get it in the can fast
which of your projects do you think
changed the most in the editing room in
ways that you weren't expecting going in
well all films take their own live
lives in in the editing let's face it
because you have to allow footage
and what you have collected to
show its own life you see you are not
putting it into a into a core set into
fetters of pre
fabricated ideas you will end up with a
stillborn baby
so i always allow the footage here come
to life and all of a sudden certain
things
are unexpected
unexpectedly beautiful and unexpectedly
uh powerful and so i i i follow i follow
the flow
of footage i i never function like a
robot i don't know if this applies
because sometimes you finance your own
things
is you're not always but in this case
and there were
some people there was for example the
alfred sloan foundation uh
came on board they heard about it and
came on board and supported the project
so it's i was not
completely alone let's face it there
it it immediately attracted attention
uh i'm curious if you could get the
financing to make anything you want yeah
what would you make and why
well i
i have my next film lined up the moment
it's fine a feature film the moment it's
like the finances are there i start
shooting now pre-production casting in
certain things i have another
feature film project lined up behind it
behind that another feature film
but i haven't written the screenplay yet
so but i can do it fast if
uh if there's some something moving some
money some avalanche little avalanche of
money kicked loose i'll be right there
and start shooting may i ask you what
the next feature film
script
that you're working that you're trying
to make well one is
at the end takes place at the end of the
civil war in sierra leone
west africa
one is about two twin sisters
one is about
a hacker
one is about oh
let's not go into all this
whichever comes first comes first sure
i was very surprised when you uh
appeared on the mandalorian and i'm just
curious
which of your friends or family were the
most surprised or excited to see you
doing something with star wars
well uh
everybody was surprised
um
but the real surprise was me playing the
real bad ass bad guy in jack reacher
because i'm so frightening
and i have no fingers left i'm blind on
one eye
i do not open fire i can't shoot a gun i
only have my quiet voice
and i had to be really frightening in
what happened
my wife friends of my wife in paris
saw the film gave her a friendly call
are you married to that man we can give
you shelter we have a guest room we are
only one one overnight flight away so i
knew i was i must have been good i must
have scared them but otherwise otherwise
of course it's a performance
otherwise
my wife if you had her next to me would
testify
credibly that i'm a fluffy husband
one of the things though is and um and
as a as someone interested in technology
and filmmaking i know that one of the
things that's so amazing about what
they're doing with that volume
technology and i'm curious if you've
seen that if with your experiences with
it is it something that you want to use
in your movies um and what your your
takeaway is for that kind of technology
basically i do not need much technology
i can do films with a very simple
primitive camera and
sound recording device and that's
basically it what i need i do not need
the state of the art newest
digital camera i can and i keep telling
young
filmmakers i want to be a
cinematographer i said why don't you
start out show me a photo that you made
without camera only with a with a
cardboard box a shoe box
in the needle and you put a hole into it
a pinhole camera you don't even have a
lens you only have photo paper at the
back
in in a black box
make a photo and show it to me
then you're on the right path you see
don't don't demand oh i can be only a
good photographer filmmaker with uh
150 000
uh with camera equipment you don't you
don't need it you can make a credible
feature film for theatrical
use release with your own cell phone
camera nowadays yes
soderbergh shot a feature on his iphone
exactly and others before him eight
eight nine years before soderbergh i've
seen a feature film very credibly done
and
a success in movie theaters so don't
don't tell me you need
this or that kind of camera
the very primitive equipment
would do as long as you have a vision
as long as you're a storyteller
as long as you're deep in your heart a
real filmmaker
um before i run out of time with you uh
which i'm just about out uh we have been
asking a lot of the people who are
coming into our studio a few of the same
questions and i'm gonna ask you um what
and i don't know if you watch tv but if
you do is there a tv show you would love
to guest star on or guest right and
direct
well i've been on the simpsons
in in guests roles
and i like the anarchy
of the humor there so if they come and
invite me again i would accept it
but otherwise any of the film the
tv shows
i stumped you
yeah i do not watch that much tv and i
don't see too many films
um
what what movie do you think you've
actually seen the most
i see films quite a few times
because my wife keeps
playing them at home we have a very
large plasma screen battle of algiers
she must have seen 60 times
so you've seen it 60 times well i start
to flee meanwhile but i've seen it at
least three four times and it's a
wonderful film or
for example
kubrick's
dr strangelove
she has seen it 70 times
70 plus times so of course i i see a
part of it
and of course i've seen uh
films by a bengal filmmaker
the apu trilogy mid 50s black and white
oh i know the apu trilogy yes
yeah yeah uphood trilogy and it's
it's a film that will never lose its uh
its appeal its humanity its beauty its
just stunning
stunningly fresh also the fact that he
filmed it so long ago yes and without
and speaking of what you just said yeah
without having modern technology yeah he
was using probably a bolex
one to 133 format and mono sound yes
and and each time you sit there and you
are stunned
by its beauty and its steps
i think that will actually be the
perfect place to stop and i do recommend
the yapoo trilogy for everyone um i just
want to say thank you so much again for
everything that you have done and will
continue to do and i wish you nothing
but the best thank you